hey everybody its Warren and it's a
great morning because we have some new
official of ventures endgame promo art
they look really awesome they don't
really reveal anything at least most of
them don't there are a few details and
some of them that I'll go over but
really what it's doing is just getting
everybody hyped up for Avengers in game
and it's doing a great job of course all
of these promo photos are of the
Avengers that are still alive there are
none of the Avengers that fell to the
decimation which makes sense because we
probably won't see much if anything of
the heroes that fell victim to the snap
Marvel is going to do everything they
can to keep spoilers from getting out
for Avengers in game so we won't really
see anything of the Fallen Heroes so
I'll go through these photos and if
there's anything to break down I will
also only a handful of days left on the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway the winner
will be announced on New Year's Day
January 1st so if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
let's start off with good old Captain
America this is a pretty classic and
retro look an infinity war captain
wasn't really Captain America he put
that mantle down but as we've learned
from leaked promo art and the Avengers
in-game teaser trailer he's going to
take on the mantle of Captain America
again in Avengers in game so we see the
scale armor on his chest plate and he's
even wearing his Captain America helmet
so the good old Captain America that we
know and love is back in the next photo
we have Natasha Romanov aka Black Widow
and what sticks out to me in this photo
is her hair now it's kind of hard to
tell because the photo is really red
black and white but it looks like her
hair is red again in the Avengers end
game trailer she still had blond hair
but we've seen leaked photos of her
having red hair and it appears that she
has red hair in this photo as well so it
seems like at some point in time in
Avengers in game we will see her with
red hair again or maybe it's a black
widow that we see in the past when they
time-travel we'll have to wait and see
we then have nebula and there's nothing
new in this photo but we know that she's
going to play a very important part in
Avengers in game because of how close
she was to Thanos and not to mention
she'll be on the benatar with Tony Stark
in the beginning of Avengers
in game so we know she's going to play a
pretty important part in the movie then
we have Rocket Raccoon again nothing
really new here but he could play a
vital part in finding Tony Stark
Rocket is a tech wiz and Tony is stuck
on the benitar which is the Guardian
ship so maybe he knows how to track it
somehow we then have ant-man and again
no differences here but we know he's
going to play a huge role in Avengers in
game especially when it comes down to
the quantum realm I think everybody is
pretty much expecting ant-man to go into
a time vortex and discover time-travel
and then show the rest of the Avengers
and this is how they'll go back in time
we then have the Hulk and this is the
same picture that was in the first
leaked promo art photo that we got for
Avengers endgame so nothing new here but
we do get a close-up look at his face
which does look a little bit more like
banner than Hulk normally does plus he
is wearing a suit so I think everybody
is pretty much expecting professor Hulk
to show up in Avengers in game we then
have Hawkeye who is actually holding a
bow and arrow
although Hawkeye will become Ronin in
Avengers in game I would be shocked if
we didn't see him with a bow and arrow
at some point in time he will most
likely be Ronan only when he's tracking
down the yakuza and when he comes back
and regroups with the Avengers who will
take on the mantle of Hawkeye again so
we will most likely see Clint be Hawkeye
and Ronan in Avengers and game we then
have Captain Marvel who is in a classic
Captain Marvel pose we learned from the
Captain Marvel prelude that she was Nick
Fury's back-up plan if the Avengers ever
failed at doing the job he would call in
Captain Marvel which we saw at the end
of Avengers infinity war and I'm
guessing in the post-credits scene of
Captain Marvel will learn a little bit
more about her role in Avengers 4 we
then have Thor who is wearing the same
armor that he was wearing an Avengers
infinity war Thor is also somebody who's
believed to maybe rescue Tony Stark
since Stormbreaker can summon the
Bifrost it would make sense for Thor to
go out and search for Tony and in the
Avengers in-game trailer it looks like
Thor is pretty beat up about the fact
that he didn't go forth a nose his head
so he probably feels some sort of guilt
about that so we know he's going to do
whatever he can to undo the snap and
Avengers end game now we have Ironman
this is an awesome photo I love that
it's just of the helmet it looks super
intense notice that it's the same armor
that he wore an Avenger
infinity war there's talk of him maybe
getting new armor in Avengers endgame
but in this photo it's still the same
armor that he wore in Avengers infinity
war it does however seem like his
shoulders and his chest plate are a
little bit different in this photo
they're actually white so he could be
wearing his quantum realm armor that we
saw in leaked photos not too long ago
then there's this awesome photo of the
Infinity Gauntlet with all of the
Infinity stones in it and it is
completely intact it's not damaged at
all now this is just promo art so it
does not mean that the Infinity Gauntlet
will be repaired in avengers endgame but
it's a really cool picture of the
gauntlet but that leads us into the
final photos of phantoms as you can see
danos is wearing his armor in every one
of these photos there's a big emphasis
on it so that means we will probably see
him wear his armor a lot more in
avengers endgame he also has his double
bladed sword so him wearing his armor
and having his sword implies that he's
not at full strength the Russo brothers
have said that fan OHS is permanently
damaged from the snap they also said
that Thanos took off his armor in
Avengers infinity war because once he
gathered two Infinity stones he felt
like he was powerful enough to not need
the armor so the fact that he's wearing
the armor and has the sword implies that
he's not at full strength and he feels
like he needs the armor to take on the
Avengers and Avengers in game also note
that in one photo he has the Infinity
Gauntlet on and in the other photo he
does not so he may not have the Infinity
Gauntlet the whole entire time in
Avengers endgame so that is it for the
new official promo art photos for
Avengers endgame let me know what you
all thought about them in the comments
down below and let me know how excited
you are for Avengers endgame also be
sure to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway for
the Infinity Gauntlet and so you can
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers and game as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]